who chose to do her residency in
pediatrics at OHSU so he now lives in
Portland and I think some of you have
met him because he's reached out to a
number of you so naturally when he
reached out to me first thing I said was
you need to come give a talk and so
that's why he's speaking today just a
brief bio and then I'll let him get
started he actually received his
undergraduate degree actually at the
same university that I did although not
in the same year and he received the
Bachelor of Science and industrial
engineering from the University of
Illinois and then master's in human
centered design and engineering up the
road at u-dub and then he went to UC San
Diego as an NLM pre-doctoral fellow and
successfully completed his degree
awesome thank you for the kind
introduction yeah it was really looking
forward to getting to share some of my
research here it often seen my
experience that despite working in kind
of the same group
I often wouldn't hear about what other
folks were doing in other parts of the
department or in violin formatic
so I was really looking forward to this
kind of cross-pollination opportunity to
show some work that I did at UC San
Diego and also probably from a little
different background from a lot of you
and my focus be even more human factors
and human-computer interaction I'm just
to get a feel for the room how many of
you are predock fellows or just PhD
students okay so we've got a number of
you so I feel your pain
you can get through it how many of you
are on the more clinical informatics
side of things okay and I know some of
you probably won't raise your hand for
either of these and they'll say I do
both but how many of you are on the more
computational side of things as well
great so
exactly so those who kind of straddle or
do both so hopefully my research will
actually touch on a little bit of both
of that I had the opportunity to look
specifically at computational notebooks
so this kind of new emerging medium that
mixes documentation with either
programming code or other things that
you can do to take action or analyze or
interact with data so as was mentioned
I'm coming up here from UC San Diego and
worked with the department of biomedical
informatics there I have my training
with them but I also received a lot of
training from the lab I was primarily in
which was a group called the design lab
it's just a whole bunch of folks who
come from all different kind of
backgrounds so we have clinicians with
anthropologists computer scientists
cognitive scientists like myself who all
study how people use information systems
how can we redesign them to make them
easier to use or more productive for
things like learning education
conducting science I want to start with
a quote actually from my advisor
highlight here Jim Hollen who's been
kind of a pioneer in information
visualization and he shared a quote with
me just about kind of the nature of
science that I found really compelling
over my time and I think it also
reflects a lot of what I want to get at
today this is a quote by Sir Peter
Medawar who was a Nobel Prize winner and
also a rather elegant writer who said
that the scientific method begins as a
story about a possible world the story
in which we invent and criticise and
modify as we go along so that it ends by
being as nearly as we can make it a
story about real life and I hope this
resonates with a lot of you and research
where we're trying to figure out what's
going on in the world we collect data we
have a potential story of how we might
explain that but then we get more data
and we update it so kind of these two
notions of it's a process of
storytelling and trying to make sense of
the data but also one that we have to
invent and criticize and modify as we go
along we realize though that wasn't
quite right but but maybe this is and
really my research just makes a simple
tweak on this phrase to say that the
same can be said of data analysis
whether that's data analysis on research
and doing computation and program
to analyze data or did an analysis that
you might do in a clinical context
trying to make sense of a patient's case
and what these values are telling you
and that this fact that data analysis is
a storytelling process has implications
for the interfaces that we design so the
broad level my research for the last
several years who's tried to answer this
question but how might we make it easier
for people that have craft in to tell
stories with data and they kind of say
why I think this is both important and
difficult to do I want to tell you a
little bit about this paper this paper
was called growth in a time of death
it's an economics paper so I think I've
cited all of our fields but it was a
rather impactful paper it was published
in 2010 and it's not to answer a rather
broad but also impactful question how
does government death affect economic
growth so this was in the time of
austerity in Europe and euro crisis and
trying to figure out do we solve things
post economic crisis with a bunch of
stimulus spending or is that just gonna
hamstring our economy in the future by
loading this up with a bunch of debt so
they collected data and the authors of
this paper came up with this figure that
countries that get over the 90%
threshold of their GDP in debt average
at best stagnation at worst mild
recession this was a huge result it was
talked about in the halls of government
in Europe by our senators here in the
United States and justifying budget
decisions the only problem was nobody
could replicate this loads of people
would read through the paper they try
and replicate the same result they were
just giving different figures so it
ended up that one group actually
contacted the original authors and said
can you just send us the files you used
for your analysis I said sure work we're
happy to share that and when they did
the second replication group found that
if they added some emitted data changed
how they did their averaging method the
weighting of different countries data
and then fix them error in Excel where
they hadn't drug the averaging function
all the way down the data column they
got a much different figure of a rather
healthy 2.2 percent so I don't bring
this up to make a economic argument of
which is right or wrong but just to make
the point that when we separate the
description
how we did an analysis and why we did it
that way from the actual steps that you
used to do it you can leave the problems
with interpretability reproducibility
and that's it's been in the news a lot
lately about crisis of reproducibility
and this I think reflects a broader
challenge that tracking and sharing data
analyses how we think about and work
with data is really difficult but a
number of levels
the analyses are often iterative you try
multiple things over and over again
until you find an explanation you think
fits many analyses lead to dead ends try
something that just doesn't work and you
don't want to document that and it just
takes a bunch of time it can be
distributed cross software platforms so
you might be using this yes or the
platform I'll look at in a minute you
put her notebook they also have a word
document and a website and emails and
capturing that in one place and handing
it off to someone or communicating
someone can be challenging and it takes
professional judgment sometimes you just
have to make a call do I log normalize
this do I not it's kind of in a
borderline and so communicating why you
chose to do something in a particular
way when it's in a great area can be
challenging now before I go further into
talking about interfaces to try and
address this issue of communicating data
analyses I want to note that data
analysis can mean a lot of different
things and will focus on one kind of
narrow description of it at first and
then I'll broaden up near the end to
talk about clinical contexts my favorite
definition of data analysis comes from
John Tukey I mean it took his tests he
also had a book exploratory data
analysis where the introduction is just
great I recommend you all read it and
then it he says data analysis is simply
looking at data to see what it seems to
say and he talks a lot about plotting
data by hand that's difficult to do with
our data sets now but what I like about
this definition is that it captures some
of the breadth of data analysis so it
can be John snows hand plotting of the
cholera outbreak in London to figure out
where is it that these cholera cases are
coming from it can be the Excel analysis
that we talked about a little bit
earlier or what I'm going to talk about
mostly which is doing data analysis via
program
as the scale and scope of data we have
gets larger than we can do by hand or
interactive systems doing it be a
programming is often how we do it now
and for the first bit of this talk I'm
gonna talk a lot about this particular
interface for data analysis called
Jupiter notebook and just to get a sense
for the room how many of you have heard
of or used Jupiter notebook before great
so there's a number of you thanks that
helps with the contrast so for those of
you who aren't familiar with it yeah for
those of you not familiar with it's
really just the programming environment
where you have different blocks of code
or cells as they're called that you can
write computer code in in a bunch of
languages python or julia and have it
execute and print the result in line so
in this particular notebook they're
importing external packages and
libraries to do fancy plotting they're
implementing the parameters of a model
they're plotting this histogram of the
data set before they do anything further
with it and so this really helps track
your analysis and you can iteratively
build it up over time at the same time
though this is also what people would
call a literate programming tool where
you can go in and put richly formatted
text images to describe why you did
things a particular way what other
experiments that you tried just to give
you a little bit further example because
I know the static you may not make sense
let's say I have a really simple
analysis where all I want to do is plot
a few XY data points and fit a line to
it I have a notebook here where I've
made a title at the top and then I've
got a couple of cells of code importing
libraries importing the data and I can
run these independently so this will
start in a second where I run this first
cell and then run the second one the
pulling data and then I'm gonna plot the
data and then I have this sum squared
error that I'm calculating how well does
this fit and like other development
environments this tells me if I type
something incorrectly or I can't
understand so I can quickly fix that get
my son squared error measure but then go
back and say well what if I add you know
an x squared term for this curve that
I'm plotting oh that seems to visually
fit that or does it fit better this way
when I calculate the sum squared error
and then you can just keep iterating
back and forth on this until you get a
result that you can fits the data set
but then there's also the second aspect
if I can go in and document things so I
can begin saying
oh be careful of overfitting you know I
can continue to increase the degree of
the polynomial and this number is going
to get lower and lower and say have a
better fit but if I just look at it that
doesn't seem to be an elegant
explanation of the data set and so this
notion of mixing text and with your
analysis is something that folks have
called computational narrative and the
makers of this particular software I
describe it this way that in order for
data and the computations that process
and visualize that data be useful for
humans they must be embedded into a
narrative a computational narrative that
tells a story for a particular audience
in context this notion has really taken
off so there's this notebook in the
middle I was showing you the our
ecosystem with our studio has their own
notebook environment the distill online
machine learning journal now uses
computational notebooks as a way of
documenting and explaining really
complex analyses just a couple of weeks
ago nature published an article about
the increasing use of tools like the
Jupiter network software I just showed
you and my favorite article from the
Atlantic earlier this year
had this rather apocalyptic headline
that says the scientific paper is now
obsolete trying to make the claim that
in the future no longer will we have
just the static PDF documents describing
our results leading the problems like
the one I discussed earlier the
economics paper now we're going to be
documenting all of our data-driven
analyses in these notebooks that mix the
actual code that can be rerun with an
analysis description of the analysis and
despite kind of the apocalyptic view I
think this is a compelling vision but
how can we use interactive tools to make
it easier to track communicate think
about in replicate analyses so broadly
my research tried to look at how are
these tools being used and how might we
improve them what are the the benefits
of this paradigm of a live documentation
that mixes action in text but also some
of the drawbacks that we need to fix and
i think it'll have implications
for this specific tool that I look at
it's often used for research it looks
like many of you use but also for
clinical documentation which we'll get
to near the end my specific question is
really how might we use these
computational notebooks to help people
track and share data analyses and I'm
going to try to talk through three
questions that I address in my research
and I may jump a little bit over the
second one just for sake of time but
first I try to just see how are these
documents being used millions of people
use them there's a lot of hype around
them how are people actually using them
are they using them to clearly document
their work or just to really quickly
hack together some code how might we
tweak their design to make it easier to
use them for this vision clearly
tracking and shearing analyses and then
how might we design them for people who
don't program for clinicians or
engineers or government workers to
benefit from mixing taking action on
data in with documentation describing
why you're doing that so then I have
these kind of three broad themes of the
research that I'll go through and first
talk about use of computational
notebooks and here I really wanted to
look on this notion of narrative that
you can be able to mix your programming
environment with this narrative
description of what's going on you want
to see is this what people are actually
doing so how much narrative
operationalized in some way is there in
a typical notebook what about notebooks
supplementing academic papers is kind of
creme de la creme vision of we're going
to be able to distribute these and have
reproducible research for all and then
how to analysts think about and use
their notebooks trying to explain why
the data that we see from the first two
questions is the way it is so this led
to three different studies and I'll jump
into the first one analyzing over a
million jupiter' notebooks from github
and before jumping into that how many of
you are familiar with github is a
platform so again a number of you for
those of you who aren't it's a platform
where typically programmers store files
or code related to a particular project
and it has nice facilities for tracking
versions of the code is updated over
time or making it easy to collaborate so
grossly oversimplified views that it's a
online file system that lots of people
can act
and so here I'm showing a particular
repository or collection of files that I
had for a prototype medical records
summarizer and you can click through the
files here at the top what's interesting
in is this platform github several years
ago started rendering notebooks in line
so they would take the the notebook kind
of proprietary document format and
render it in line so that you could
easily share with the collaborator of
the notebook document they can look
through it without needing the notebook
software downloaded on their computer
there's a great way to share these
notebooks with others and share analyses
that have some description of what's
going on but since the introduction of
this feature in 2015 there's been a
somewhat exponential growth in the
number of notebooks on github here I
mean Jupiter notebooks and when I ran
this study they just reached the 1
million notebooks threshold so for my
first phase of research I downloaded all
of these built a scraper scraped all
these documents and then just computed a
bunch of features about this corpus of
documents so looking at how many cells
or the box of code and texts there were
how many lines of code words of markdown
what libraries they import there's
dozens of things I looked at and I don't
have time to get into a bunch of the
results we have more documented
elsewhere but I think the most striking
result came from one of the simplest
analyses which was simply how long are
these things and what's the main content
so I'm going to show you a series of
three graphs on the left-hand side I
have the percent of all notebooks the
percent of all million in this data set
so 0 5 10 to 20 and then on the x-axis I
have a log plot of the length of the
notebook via some measure so here the
length and number of cells the street
blocks of code text if somebody had
written we see a somewhat log normal
plot maybe about a dozen two dozen cells
chunks in these notebooks on median if
we do the same kind of plot for the
number of lines of code that are in the
the median notebook we see something
similar log normal plot but then there's
this artifact on to the left where
there's a somewhat of a proportion maybe
three percent that have no code
whatsoever this is kind of odd this is
really a programming environment
what's going on here it turns out a lot
of these are like index or table of
contents notebooks people use them to
provide links to other networks so they
might have an analysis that spans eight
notebooks and these are just the table
of contents once what's really striking
is if we look at the number of words of
text so that description that you get
and we see maybe a log normal bump off
to the right than a huge chunk over a
quarter of these million notebooks have
no text whatsoever and when we look at
them a lot of them are just loose
collections of code that people have
written and not really documented so
this is our first clue that at least
that scale with this data set
maybe these notebooks aren't being used
for this narrative description let me
clearly describe my research to you you
but maybe more just as a playground for
program a caveat to this result though
many of these notebooks seem to be for
course assignments particularly machine
learning courses so when we go in and
look at the descriptions that people put
in these notebooks the top keywords once
we clean them are things like learning
machine deep learning project Udacity
nanodegree Kaggle and some of you may
recognize these popular online platforms
for learning how to do machine learning
deep learning so a couple notes it may
just be that students on these platforms
don't care if somebody else can read
their programming environment they're
just trying to get a result or it could
be that the teachers of these classes
don't really instill that you need to
document what you're doing and what
you're thinking does you do the analysis
either way this could contaminate the
results um so we said all right let's
look at what some consider the creme de
la creme the prime use case for these
notebooks reproducible academic research
but rather than static papers you can
describe your research in a notebook so
we said maybe those notebooks that
supplement academic publications will
have more narrative so on the right this
is a paper that came out of UCSD a
couple years ago published in Nature
microbiology some microbiome research
and they also released a set of
notebooks on how they did every single
step of this research so what we did is
we went back to our big corpus or
million notebooks and we looked
specifically for ones that were in
collections of files
a description filed that linked to a
published paper that linked to do i link
of that paper or an archive preprint
just some marker that this supplemented
an academic publication we come through
that by hand and then just try the
purposely sample from a bunch of
different disciplines
let's grab some machine learning ones
let's grab some ones from astronomy grab
some ones from genetics and then we
selected about 150 of those to look at
it detail from 50 repositories so you
can imagine 50 academic papers and the
about three notebooks on average that go
along with each paper and I am another
research assistant read through each of
these notebooks and for each block of
text tried to code by hand what is this
text doing what is it here for is it
just describing the steps of the
analysis we ran a PCA we tried to see if
it was log normal we tried to do this
was it describing reasoning the reason
we're doing this kind of a check is
because we can't do this kind of
analysis unless it's normally
distributed or is it describing the
results if you look at this graph what
you'll notice is there's an anomaly here
so when we did this hand coding the
first thing we noticed was of all the
the notebooks in this corpus the 150
only about 3/4 had text that was
anything more than just a header just a
title to the notebook so of those three
quarters that had somewhat descriptive
text about 88% of those use the text
somewhere to describe steps but only
about 1/3 used it for this higher level
describing reasoning why they did
something or interpreting results so
here we see if we look a little more
qualitatively at what these notebooks
are being used for even in this academic
face it's not being used for rich
description that's simply a labeling of
the steps of the analysis and it can be
really hard to replicate an analysis if
we just see they did a PCA but you don't
know why they did that so to try and
understand from these two dimensions why
we're seeing that these notebooks aren't
being used to clearly communicate
research in the way that we're expecting
or that commentators are expecting
reagent a third study where we interview
data analysts so we grabbed 15 analysts
from around our campus range of
experience levels different labs so
computational biology pharmacology
astronomy and then we just simply ask
them to show us a notebook they've been
working on recently walk us through the
structure of that notebook talk about
who else had access to it there are a
couple of nuggets we got out of this
interview data to help explain why the
networks we saw were so messy had so
little documentation of reasoning or
results one was that people just viewed
the notebooks as personal like this is
my personal programming environment I
don't think other people are gonna be
able to follow my programming style or
understand why did things why would I
show it to them
so one said a notebook is a very
personal thing so even if I would say
okay here that mate please look into it
it wouldn't be very helpful because it's
very much reflecting my style in my
programming style this resonates with
prior research that shows many analysts
even collaborative labs don't share
their script files they just replicate
it or recreate it another big finding
was that everyone we talked to without
being prompted said my notebooks are
really messy and were kind of
embarrassed about this so I said
analyses are iterative over time it just
kind of gets away from me I have a hard
time figuring out how I got to this end
results I'm not going to show somebody
else how the sausage was made I'm just
gonna send a final figure and hopefully
don't ask too many questions so they
said things like mine feels like a mess
mine feels like if somebody else looked
at it they wouldn't have any idea what
really what order I ran the code in or
like why I did things others said it's
not how I strive for them to be contains
ugly code or my favorite there's dirty
tricks that I did in there that I have
to clean out I mean oh the result will
still be the same but still I don't want
anyone to see that on the flip side
people said yeah but I you know I can
clean it up I can make it like those
ones that we dream about having for a
couple of reasons you've ever just for
my own sanity to make it easier to
navigate a really long notebook to say I
try to document at least the tasks
because it's so easy to get lost and all
the different specific questions I'm
trying to answer with this analysis so
I'll just put in question before all the
steps of code to do it or another
analyst who's in more of a comes
Colten roll we're labs would come to her
with a data set and she'd have to send
the analysis back said well really I
have to put in the explanation of what
I'm doing is there to understand what's
going on it's tedious but it's kind of
the whole point so she says the thing I
usually end up having to put in it's
tedious but it's kind of the whole point
is what are the conclusions that I drew
the interpretation that's not something
that can ever be auto-generated so this
speaks to why we saw so little of this
in the academic notebooks you looked at
it's just a tedious process to stop and
reflect what am i doing
what are these results mean and write it
when you really just want to do the next
turn on the crank in the iteration cycle
to see if you can improve the result and
we had another participant who really
validated the same small ously lab
meetings and then actually writing the
paper the only times we have to sit and
be like why am I doing this what am I
going to do what am i finding though I
think it means
and so my collaborators and I really
think this shows attention and data
analysis between exploring data which is
iterative and messy and generates a lot
of byproducts and can be hard to
understand and then stopping to reflect
and explain the process and while we
have this vision of this document that
can mix that era t'v messy writing code
with the more thoughtful explaining
there's this tension here that's just
hard to get over so we have to figure
out how can we redesign this environment
so people are more likely to write clear
notebooks that are easier to use for
research this led to the second line of
work which I'm going to try and grease
through a little bit more quickly just
to get to some of the more clinical
applications but in this line of work we
said how might we encourage a just make
it easier to turn messy notebooks into
cleaner ones and we took a particular
point of view there's a lot of ways you
can do this but we said can we make it
immediately beneficial to do this clean
can we make it so it's easier to
navigate the notebook or to track your
versions if you do a little bit of
cleaning and that way you might be more
likely at the very end to have a clean
notebook that you're willing to share
with others so in order to do that we
built a really simple extension but
simply let you folds portions of the
notebook that you think you don't need
it this time so we're back with my
plotting notebook let's say I
the first few cells here I don't really
need to see right now I can click on
these click a button and go hide and I
can name this hidden section this is my
imports and data section if I click on
this it will open up to the side for me
and I can look at those details but I
don't need to see it I can just collapse
it have a table of contents view so we
wanted to see does this lead to people
writing cleaner notebooks making it
easier to reuse somebody else's
notebooks we ended up running two
studies one a more controlled lab study
where we had data science undergrads use
the tool and solve it in some cases they
were able with the folding some more
quickly
continuing analysis somebody else had
done so this kind of collaborative case
if I do the analysis I hand it off to
another grad who's working with me and
in the folded case it's easier for them
to work with that notebook I want to
focus a little bit on the second one
though again for sake of times let me
just scroll to that portion so for the
second one what we did is we did a
technology probe which in HCI in the
computer interaction just refers to
releasing an early stage technology to
see how people will use it what other
features they may want how it changes
how they interact with others in their
work so we had a really small sample
there's three analysts from different
labs on our campus but we had them use
this full beam tool that we call Janice
for several weeks just in your normal
everyday work your normal analyses not a
contrived test just use it and see if
it's helpful then we interviewed them at
the end of each week and they came back
with some feedback about what worked
what didn't said it's really helpful for
doing the analysis because before I'd
have seven or eight plots that all look
the same and I'd mix up which one I'm
working on but now I can hide everything
except the one I'm working on currently
but the thing I think was most
interesting was how they talked about it
helped them with collaboration that they
were able to take a messy notebook
quickly clean it up and then use it when
talking with a colleague
so they one of the things they told us
let's see if I can get the clicker
working again yeah was that at baseline
using the standard software without
folding but presenting from notebooks
and context like this or in a labbing
just painful they wanted to do it they
wanted to be able to show the full steps
of an analysis but they just had trouble
doing so so I said when I presented
versions of this notebook in our weekly
meetings
I'm always scrolling scrolling scrolling
it's long and people get distracted or
another said it's all slide decks now
we've tried but we haven't had much
success using these notebooks as a
presentation tool we've given up on that
they're just too long there's too much
in there to make it useful on the flip
side though when they use this folding
tool Janice it made it easier to quickly
just clean up the notebook use it in a
lab meeting and if they needed to they
can look at the details but they could
say well I can kind of just quickly
scroll through the notebook and know
that every cell that's still left is a
cell that I wanted to show for some
reason so then I breeze through the
second section but we tried to show that
we can reduce this tension between
generating a bunch of mess and
reflecting and cleaning it up by making
it easy not only to mix code and
descriptive text but also quickly
rearrange it quickly fold in hide
sections so you can reuse the same
artifact both for your messy exploratory
work and quickly explained it's someone
else now the last bit of my research
that has a more clinical focus was
saying okay there's obviously some
challenges with mixing live-action data
analysis in the very same document we
used to document it mixing that
reflective documentation and then the
action we get this tension but there's
also some real benefits there's a reason
why millions of people have in the last
couple years
adopted this platform for data analysis
is there a way that we can make this
paradigm of mixing documentation and
action useful for people who don't
program in other contexts but still
interact with a bunch of data I looked
at clinicians but you can imagine
engineers or government workers who are
trying to interact with the data set so
we have this broad notion kind of
theater of theoretical level what about
non-programmers ie those who don't know
a general programming language like
Python or R how might we enable them to
mix analytical steps with their
commentary and results and I'll
demonstrate one approach using a
domain-specific language applied to
clinical records
this was work I did with the Veterans
Medical Research Foundation several
years ago and this was back at the time
where before the VA awarded the contract
for updating their medical records
discerner they said well maybe we'll try
and redesign these things on our own so
they had given a research grant to this
group to say help us think about what
might we want to do with that new
medical record system how could we
redesign it to be more useful
so was seeking to redesign this legacy
system the Vista CPRS and one of the
things that this group noticed that has
been documented elsewhere is that
medical records are often fragmented and
that can make them difficult to navigate
and use specifically there's kind of a
divide between structured information
say demographic information orders
family history problem lists that lives
a structured data and then the
unstructured information clinical notes
where you might reference that
structured information but not as
structured away and so people have tried
to make it easier to move data back and
forth between these two forms or things
like that phrases where you can say let
me pull in all the demographic
information and just populate it in the
notes or the orders or the problem
history but this group said well what if
we went the other way what if we let
clinicians write in the note and then we
parse the text in real time to generate
structured data would that be helpful
would that reduce double documentation
time or navigation time they look
specifically at parsing medication
orders and I'm going to jump over this
was based off of some of their prior
work showing the clinicians spend a lot
of time in notes and then the order
section and then they spend a lot of
time transitioning between the notes in
the orders so a bunch of their time and
a bunch of the switches in the interface
went between those two sections what I
hope this group do was prototype just a
dead simple web interface to test this
simple idea so most of this is
boilerplate just a fake to simple
medical record in the middle we have a
text editing section where they can
start writing and say a soap note so a
clinical note what's going on here is as
soon as the clinicians type of
specific keyword in this case hash med
what we're gonna do is open up a
drop-down almost search dialog you can
imagine Google search and we've
connected them to their their back-end
database their formulary of what
medications they can order so they can
start typing things like simvastatin
they can just tab complete or hit the
down arrow to complete that then we'll
show them what dosages we have of that
in the formulary then they can just keep
typing I know this is hard to see so
I'll just zoom in what's going on is
this they're typing here above it we
have these little blue blobs of texts
that are saying this is the part of the
order that we're recognizing the
structured data that we're pulling out
in real time and then above it in the
actual note we're just placing exactly
what they've written in there so they
can use whatever shorthand they want and
we'll try and parse it so at the end
they hit enter at the end of this kind
of search box and they now have this
structured text data in here that can be
free text but we're parsing it to
structured data and what this buys them
is when they go to place the order most
of that information that we parse these
already there there may be a thing or
two that they have to check but they can
largely just sign the order and not have
to document I want to start the patient
on this and then go and have to enter
that via dropdowns later we had a couple
questions about how this might work this
is just the prototype system exploring
this idea so we want to see what types
of shorthand would clinicians use if
we're gonna build an ontology of
something on top of rxnorm directly to
parse all of the shorthand like a sa for
aspirin how big does an ontology have to
be is it just going to be an intractable
problem or is it a pretty limited set of
things we're going to have to recognize
what other functionality might
clinicians want now this is a seed of an
idea but what else does it make them
think of that they may want in a record
that mixes both documentation and taking
action placing orders and then do
clinicals just even see this as useful
we as researchers think it might be but
with their experience and data they
practice is it even useful for them so
we did a quick usability study with 8
clinicians they have been to patient
scenarios where they had to write a
basic soap note and then order
for meditations and we tell them the
medication order in this way trying to
be mostly free text and just see how
they would place this order in the note
so the first question just what
shorthand they used we noticed that for
certain parts of the order like the
medication the dose the form and the
route the shorthand they used was pretty
standardized so if they were gonna say
take it orally they'd say P O or oral
but there weren't a lot of different
variations that we spent in our small
set however for things like schedule the
quantity of the medication the number of
refills or how to pick it up things that
clinicians said they often don't put in
the interface anyway there was just a
whole bunch of different ways that they
try to input this so that part of the
deontology of trying to recognize that
from free text could be really difficult
would be a lot of different things that
we'd have to differentiate between as
for what additional functionality this
made clinicians think of it really
validated the benefit of mixing
documentation with being able to take
action directly in the note not having
to go to another screen so they said
things like additional parsing would be
great to know parse active problems I
can just sit down chat with a patient
look at them and start typing and if
that just parsed what I was typing the
structured data for the problem with but
be great or what about information
retrieval not just inputting structured
information but pulling it back the
other way like other systems do being
able to just type retrieve most recent
colonoscopy have a summary pop up in the
note that would be great
and then lastly they validated that this
direction this mixing of documentation
and structured data entry and retrieval
was really beneficial
so saying I love not having the screen
to place orders the thing that I really
like about this is having the order
directly tied to the documentation so in
this case we show a domain-specific
language really just a small language
for parsing medication orders can be
used to design this notebook for
non-programmers this notebook that mix
is free text with what looks like free
text but is being partially structured
data and this is really just a markup
language so I'm going to think jump over
the thesis statements here because this
isn't my dissertation defense and also
implications just to sum what I think
are interesting future directions so I
mentioned domain-specific languages as a
way to enable people who don't program
to still interact with data and in the
HCI community one of the really
interesting trends that's come out
recently is being able to do data
analysis via chat and so in this case
what they have is this chat window here
and then off to the right is a panel
where you can see results of the
analysis so in the chat the but the user
is basically saying things like I want
to analyze the flower data set it'll ask
oh I noticed for flower data set files
on your computer which one did you want
oh I wanted the third one how did you
want to analyze it compare two sets do
you want a t-test or an ANOVA and then
would link to no materials on that but
you could just type me a chat what you
were wanting to do and then it would
turn that into the code necessary to do
the analysis and then on the the
clinical side I think there's a lot more
room although there's certain barriers
with vendors or regulation but a lot
more room for innovating on medical
records to say how can we make the
clinical note the documentation more
active so folks like that the Reagan
Streep Institute have already done
similar things to what the group I work
with prototypes where they notice in the
note that you mentioned the oxacillin so
they pull up in a sidebar do you want to
order amoxicillin and then there's also
a system several years ago by Lauren
Wilcox at Columbia that did data
retrieval so it would notice you
mentioned arterial blood pressure in the
notes if you hit enter after that it's
going to open a side panel where we're
going to plot the arterial blood
pressure data for the last couple days
and you can select data that you want to
pull into the note so I think with that
I will stop because I have been talking
here for a while and just open up the
floor for questions and comments thanks
for listening
yeah yeah thanks great talk and I think
probably most clinical people in the
room can see a lot of value of this one
of the one of the things that sometimes
happens I wonder if your research looked
at this is things that are obvious great
solutions to relatively common
situations break down when you get in
when situations get more complex I can't
remember where I was really I don't know
if it was in this conference or
somewhere about someone had some system
that was great for putting in orders
until it came to tapering steroids a
couple weeks ago yeah okay that's what I
thought
did you wear your cases complex enough
to look at what might happen when things
didn't fit into your narrower paradigm
so that the infirm so that the time
people might say from the
straightforward cases could get could be
a lot more difficult in in a more
complex situation so we tried to vary
the cases and I'd have to look back at
the actual ones that we use to give you
a better answer on the variability there
but I do think that's a valid concern
like we may have made it easier to do
80% of things but if this system then
makes it harder to do that tale of 20%
and much harder to where you're now
wasting a bunch of time trying to figure
out because in this system we don't give
a lot of feedback we do have a drop-down
system that you could fall back on but
that was kind of harder to discover so I
think the question is if you can make it
easier for the everyday case how do you
make sure that it's not just painfully
difficult for the case that still comes
up once a week and I don't have a lot of
data on that but I do think that's one
of the real challenges here yeah yeah
I was really interested in the first
part where you you know show the survey
programmers and well they say they're
not this is the fitness actually my
point you know that these scientists
they're they're saying that they don't
want to share their notebooks they're
too messy they have to fix this they
have to fix that they're kind of
complaining about all the things that
quote unquote real programmers who
developed an a-team have to do but
they're kind of making the excuse that
they're not real programmers so they
shouldn't have to but really they are
programming and really they do have to
do these things and as more and more
science is essentially gun
computationally with programs and it's
so easy to make this big I was I guess
the question is a bit larger it seems
like we're at a point where there is a
really a necessary culture change and
people who are doing science have to
inherit some of the discipline that
comes from programming and other things
and so I just been wondering you know
what you thought being an HDI person
about you know how much of that is is is
new and better tools how much of that is
education and re-education you know how
do we get the people that are doing
science to be the studious about their
programming and the shareability of that
so that we can actually reproduce the
science amount yes some some some
confidence in it because I'll tell you
right now my confidence in the science
that's published now has dropped because
they don't want to show anybody their
stuff and they believe it'll work you
know that was a really nice nice quote
you know I need to have to change this
and get rid of this happen I know it
will stop us after so you don't have the
same result that's a completely
fallacious
yeah so I'm asking you know the person
who wants to you know so a couple
comments one back to the you know
comparing to wet lab work one of our
participants actually brought that well
I'll get there but one of our
participants brought up and saying you
know it's only really when I publish the
paper that I go back to think that this
is so different than my chem lab days
where at a very specific way discipline
way that I had to record the analysis
and the steps of the study and I just
don't do that in this computational
system that's your question I think
there's a mix of things we can do one
there's programs like software carpentry
or data carpentry that go around and try
and train those in the sciences how did
you scientific computing what's some
rigor so using things like version
control unit testing those kinds of
things I think there's some bit we can
do on the interface side so things like
hey you've run five different tests on
this dataset now you're diluting your
p-value essentially so if you're going
to come out and say that this is
significant you just run a whole bunch
of tests until you've found one that was
those are kinds of things that we can
track I do think a lot of it has to be
at the cultural level though both on the
educational training side and the lab
expectations as an example I showed
earlier I think is a nature biology and
microbiology paper that came out of the
lab at UC San Diego that lab has
essentially half of the lab that focuses
on the biology and microbiome work and
another half that really acts as a
software development group they sit down
and they do code reviews their writing
unit tests
and all these things that you would see
in a software development group and
that's their expert in using
contribution to science I don't think we
even have a baseline so this you know
giving a verbal command to compare this
to that so I and you just mentioned that
that there should be some kind of
decision support in there so I'll give
an example twenty years ago when I was
working at a health system I had a
doctor say to me I want you to compare
the mortality after cabbage for this
hospital versus that hospital I knew not
to do that because of the risk
adjustment that had to be done and he
just want a straight comparison so is
there any kind of I mean you mentioned
the correcting for P and I can see where
people who aren't trained strongly in
science and programming kind of like
what Aaron was saying might ask it to do
comparisons that could be misleading
so how even is there any that kind of
guidance in there with these tools
there's not much of that guidance in
there now that I know of I think it's an
interesting question especially in
educational contexts if you can use
tools like this to provide guidance so
you can imagine in a class where
students are learning how to do data
analysis and we'll just do the p-value
dilution thing the after they try
checking the same data set three or four
times a pop-up comes up insides like hey
you know what this is this is going on
and it gives you a lot of information
about why why you don't want to do this
that's more pedagogical for those who
are more practising data analysis I
would almost imagine something like
computational spellcheck so we get
spellcheck that just slightly highlights
you might want to change this
looks a little funky the grammars off
the spellings off and in that context
you may not want something yelling at
you all the time but you do something it
thinks is incorrect yeah so grammar for
coding practice you but just how can you
make it lightweight so that you notice
it but it's not jumping in your face and
stopping you from continuing flight yeah
I know that but I already corrected for
this it just didn't register that I've
done that so I don't I don't know of any
work in that area yet but I think that's
a promising area especially
pedagogically because that seems to be
an area where it would be easier to
detect the common errors and then you
can channel it into a learning episode
would be really valuable I have two
question might be related first is how
do you concern the case where the input
for some example someone writing a note
or something like that and you try to
link it to an order or something like
that but it's not cleared enough what
they want it only if it says
insufficient amount of data that was
provided how do you reconcile those
situations and the second question is if
there is if it's a little bit amigos or
maybe there were just too many options
to choose from how do you limit or make
sure it's just not information overload
for people who are trying to to use that
function yeah yeah so the first problem
you mentioned is the Midas touch problem
at least how it's referred to in a lot
of HCI communities at least as I
understand the problem you're describing
where essentially if you have the system
always honor always recognizing it's
like Midas always touching things and
turning the gold even when you didn't
intend for that thing to happen so
that's where you build in a clutch so
basically say okay now engage this parsh
in their recognition now disengage it so
in our case that's why we had that you
have to type hash in headfirst to be
able to say okay this is a medication
I'm doing we wanted it to be lightweight
and still with your hands on the
keyboard rather than clicking something
so it's just a quick invoke I'm going to
place a medication order and then hit
enter to turn it off and that was our
way of building
watching so that it's not just always
parsing all the time the other way that
you can do it is like the medical gofer
system it doesn't act on it it's just on
the side panel sags it looks like you
wanted to do this are you this what you
wanted to do and you can click on it and
that's a that's another way to address
the second problem you brought up what
if it's just ambiguous that's where
research and domain-specific languages
has said does there need to be
one-to-one mapping can there be one that
many and when there's a one-to-many
mapping how do you clarify and so
systems for life data cleaning the data
Wrangler or trifecta system has done
that where you can select a way that you
want to clean a data set your selection
may be ambiguous and so it'll say it
looks like one of these four things we
went ahead and cleaned the data set in
each of those four ways and it looks
like this way of cleaning it is going to
lead to the cleanest data so we rank
that highest so there's ways that you
can do kind of predictive analytics in
the background it's ended years to say
you probably met this is that correct
and then ask for them to select that um
thank you great talk and I just want to
say I had before the question great that
you also put your webpage in the
description
I was curious when you found those
articles that you looked at like 145 I
think were there do you have an estimate
how many of those were clinical medical
journals then it was from the data set
that we've gotten so folks who have
posted on github I've been trying to
purposely sample for a diverse range so
I'd say probably relatively few our
clinical journals because it's things
like astronomy biology machine learning
that are using computational notebooks
more than the medical journals like I
don't know that I've seen anyone going
jami'a or JAMA or New England Journal of
Medicine that has a notebook attached to
it but I've seen more and like more
thank you the reason why I'm asking
instances I think the culture changed
towards more transparency and the
scientists like really like the biggest
challenge for it for this and I'm
suspecting from what I've been like I've
been familiar with like the reproducible
research for a couple of years now but
I've been keeping my eye out in medical
journals and maybe seen once or twice
something and I I honestly think that
culture change has to go at least in
part through the publishers that they
need to emphasize more like that they
value that and they look for where like
like submissions where the
decision-making and the processing of
the steps are like hidden are obfuscated
versus where it's made transparent the
readers and the publisher said you'll
you should get on board with this again
I'm just concerned that the medical
field is probably gonna lag behind other
disciplines there for a while there's
more complexity it's easier if you're an
astronomy to make your work reproducible
kids look there's no human subjects data
involved they didn't just post their
whole dataset
who cares hey it's even better if
somebody cites it you're just looking at
asteroids or points of life and so there
are other berries too reproducibility
beyond writing it clearly or having the
platform that are things like how do I
clean the data how do I share it so
things like homomorphic encryption of
those things that have really been
pioneered in the medical context I think
are some of the blocking barriers yes
there's some culture change issues but I
think it's easier in some of the other
fields to do that I mean for me
I ended up posting my full data set of
all million notebooks online and the
only way I could do that is because I
had scraped data from github in the
first place it was a public repository
in the first place
if it wasn't that way it's very hard for
me to post any kind of human subjects
data like my interview data it's hard to
post that online
just a quick full of I agree with that
there there are different extends to
which you can make it transparent but
still there is something to be said at
least for making the steps the
algorithms that you used for your
statistical processing even if you
cannot publish the data every reader
will understand if you publish the steps
that you went through in your
statistical analysis it still allows a
critical evaluation more so than if it's
just enumerated and most of the details
are appreciated so I was just gonna make
the comment that the the point that dr.
Cohen brought up that was about
computational people having taking on
the same discipline that bench
scientists and train themselves to do in
terms of a lab notebook but I tie that
back into the statistic you showed about
all the notebooks that only have code
and no documentation and having to do
with courses and so we're what we're
seeing there is that a lot of these are
probably homework assignments or they're
you know exercises and so the goal is
like use this function here's the here's
the thing run this machine learning
model on it see what you get make the
graph and that's that's the homework
assignment so you do that right you're
done so maybe that's the place that you
start instilling that discipline is is
that the instructors each you start
adding the requirement but the things be
documented as having been an instructor
that greatly will increase the burden on
you know the graters of what they have
to do you know but anyway it seems like
that seems like you kind of identified
where that you know at least one place
where that could begin
completely agree
one last question it really might be
more of a comment but you know I'm
intrigued you know you mentioned you
mentioned a second use case for medical
records you know which is pulling in
data and summarizing things and whether
that's a potential solution to one of
the biggest problems with the text in
medical records of the proliferation of
copy and paste and you know whether
instead people can basically you know
paste in a link or maybe ideally you
know like the first you know three
sentences you know with the dot dot dot
then they could click and then go get
the whole report you know which would be
more explicit that they're copying and
pasting but a lot of people do copy and
paste because records because the entry
of data is so time-consuming yeah
another system that Lauren Wilcox built
wall at Columbia she's now at Georgia
Tech addressed that by using
transclusion which is really just
linking to where that data came from so
it even do things like you could write
in okay arterial blood pressure is this
thing right now but update me if it goes
above or below this range or updated
every 12 hours in the note and so
there's issues with you have to figure
out is this supposed to be just a once
and for all record is it supposed to be
a living document you give into some
hairy trade-offs there but there are
ways to as you say just kind of tweak or
link to or give an appetizer as to the
information that's over there and if you
really want to using that folding
feature you can expand it and look at it
but you don't need to see the whole
thing thank you all for coming
[Applause]